bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal sur tv
fil 78 nous reviendrons aujourd'hui sur
l'histoire de saint cyr l'école
l'établissement scolaire jean jaurès
fête ses 100 ans en un siècle d'histoire
et une exposition proposée par une
association locale dont les responsables
sont en plateau
et puis l'espace rambouillet fait appel
à une société blinoise canopée pour
réaliser été prises de vues de son parc
à led vous le voyez de drones retour sur
le succès de cette entreprise locale et
comme chaque vendredi retour sur
l'essentiel de la semaine journée du don
du sang journée de mobilisation contre
les violences aux personnes âgées et
ouverture du bac 2015 également nous y
reviendrons en seconde partie de ce
journal
c'était ce vendredi matin en préfecture
les pompiers à versailles les pompiers
yvelinois réunis à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie de commémoration pour les
hommes tomber au feu le département qui
compte 42 caserne pour près de 100 mille
interventions par an la cérémonie a été
suivie d'une remise de médailles le tout
en présence d'élus et de représentants
des casernes donc du département
chaque année la france s'honore les
corporations qui s'investissent
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
des sapeurs pompiers est donc un rappel
des valeurs du corps départemental des
sapeurs pompiers dessus des yvelines et
surtout un instant de mémoire ou sept
ans pompier décédé en service cette
année c'est une double reconnaissance
puisque effectivement de manière en
rotation l'ile-de-france et à l'est de
l'île de france participeront comment
dire un au défilé du 14 juillet c'est
réellement comment dire essentiel parce
que ça ça positionne les sapeurs
pompiers dans l'institution français de
manière générale c'est une
reconnaissance
et cette année c'est l'ile-de-france et
c'est le plus beau département
d'ile-de-france les yvelines qui vont
assurer non ça c'est fait pas le dire à
mes collègues qui vont assurer comment
dire le commandement du bataillon
sociale et les agents du conseil
départemental des yvelines qui ont
débrayé aujourd'hui donc à la sortie de
l'assemblée départementale pour en cause
la position des élus sur le découpage du
département et la répartition des
effectifs 311 emplois ont été supprimés
en deux ans elle les syndicats cgt fo
soutiennent cette action des agents qui
seront en grève le 30 juin prochain on
écoute la déléguée force ouvrière c'est
au micro de william l on va vers une
suppression du département
on va vers une imprécision complète du
service départemental on sait pas du
tout comment il va se structurer et on
voit bien qu'il va y avoir des
communautés d'agglomération qui seront
plus ou moins bien dotées plus ou moins
bien
h comment dire qu'ils auront des
services plus ou moins structurés
cohérent et
doté de moyens donc en fait là le
dossier qui nous est présenté ne nous
permet pas du tout de vérifier comment
va être réparti les moyens et surtout
sur quels éléments
donc nous continuerons étant donné que
le conseil départemental vient de voter
ce budget et vient également de débattre
sur ce sujet de la réforme donc
territoriales qui ne changent pas d'avis
qu'il continue pour si dans cette dans
cette direction une société qui ne
connaît pas à l'abri de la crise canopée
dans les yvelines elle propose
d'utiliser des drones pour réaliser des
prises de vue inédite c'est à l'espace
rambouillet que nous les avons suivis
puisque le site vient de faire appel à
ses services florane parfait et william
elle pour les images
avez vous déjà vu l'espace rambouillet
sous cet angle la forêt vue du ciel à
plusieurs centaines de mètres du sol
les images inédites pour les réaliser le
parc a fait appel à l'entreprise
innovante n canopée une façon de
promouvoir le site naturel avant l'été
l'idée c'est de mettre le visiteur au
coeur de ces petits films d'avoir du
mouvement dedans donc de susciter on
regarde le donner une image des émotions
qu'on pourra vivre je vais faire une
rotation autour de l'arbre
je jure faire des plans autour de cet
ambre trois mois de tournage ont été
nécessaires à edouard jany et son équipe
pour réaliser ses films sur le parc
la fauconnerie et les grands animaux
visible dans la forêt pour moi
finalement c'est assez court sachant que
c'est pas trois mois plan ces trois mois
avec une journée de tournage de journée
de tournage par semaine et puis souvent
du tournage qui se prévaut à la veille
puisque la météo est bonne et qu'il faut
qu'on en profite peu de temps pour
couvrir les 250 hectares du site
dans les yvelines il existe plusieurs
parcs de ce type alors il faut se
démarquer et communiqué cent mille
visiteurs visitent chaque année l'espace
rambouillet qui espère attirer de
nouveaux curieux pour ce tournage
commandé par la lnf canopée à utiliser
plusieurs drones ainsi que sont calmes
quad une technologie qui a convaincu le
parc naturel du coup je pense que pour
mettre en valeur des sites comme les
nôtres ici c'est un outil qui est
vraiment géniale qui peut se comparer
anciennement aller kopter mais
heureusement avec des coûts qui sont pas
seuls les hélicoptères si ç'avait été
une option hélicoptère je pouvais même
pas songé à discussion plus de deux
secondes quoi c'est pas dans nos moyens
et dans le budget donc c'est une manière
vraiment de démocratiser ce type d'image
environ 1200 euros la location d'un
drone pour la journée contre 2500 euros
de l'heure pour un militaire la
différence de prix est de taille
pourtant un tournage avec des drones ne
s'improvise pas en fait nous allons
marcher le long
côté soleil le long de l'ombre d'accord
vous face au soleil je vais prendre sur
le côté comme ça alors
et je vous dis quand c'est bon on est
énormément d'obstacles on a des
perturbations le vent aussi qu'ils sont
liés au relief et aux différents arbres
donc chaque décollage est très
particulier très différent des indigents
c'est pour ça qu'on fait qui a rien
d'anodin en fait quand on fait décoller
un drone on vérifie tout à l'avant sont
a passé dix minutes là à vérifier qu'il
n'y avait pas une branche qu'on n'avait
pas vu un vison qu'on n'avait pas
identifiées là on est obligé de
scénariser aujourd'hui parce qu'on filme
avec un drone ou pour des raisons de
sécurité il faut que les gens qui sont
là soient des habitués
ce qui seront survolées par un drone ce
qui n'est pas anodin et puis il faut
qu'on cale tout pour savoir exactement
où le drone va passer comment ils
doivent réagir en cas de problème etc
un travail payant pour entreprises qui
s'est lancée dans la prise de vue avec
des drones l'année dernière en plus de
son activité de communication avec ses
différents moyens techniques et de
production
le concept proposé par canopée séduit
les acteurs du territoire
l'entreprise vient de signer plusieurs
contrats avec des acteurs économiques
importants comme le crédit agricole sa
est un petit peu plus long que prévu
mais pas lié à la crise voit quoi que ce
soit vous m'aviez juste à la météo donc
depuis qu'il fait beau depuis un mois à
peu près bon envol beaucoup on tombe
beaucoup ont fait beaucoup d'image et on
se rend compte qu'on a bien fait de se
diriger dans ce sens là et la façon dont
on le fait semble fonctionner donc donc
c'est plutôt positif avec la saison
estivale edouard génie espère multiplier
les tournages c'est le moment pour qu'à
nos pays de prendre de la hauteur vie
locale depuis le 12 avril la commune de
montigny le bretonneux dispose d'un
nouveau marché même s'il est encore
restreint ses commerçants accueille les
clients tous les dimanches à partir de
8h30 mélanie poker c'est un marché qui
revit depuis maintenant deux mois la
place jacques heures à montigny le
bretonneux accueille une dizaine de
commerçants voulaient souvent ici
ban de temps en temps en fait plus
depuis que c'est le marché bio
d'ailleurs que qu'avant ah ben je suis
content en tout cas pas a priori c'est
des produits
pour certains c'est des produits bio
donc on n'a pas toujours la possibilité
d'aller sur des marchés bio sur
versailles où le bio donc l'une des
particularités de ce marché voulu par la
commune de montigny un argument pour
attirer le client
ils sont attirés mais il faut leur
parler il faut leur présenter il faut
leur
tout simplement leur expliquer ce qu'on
fait notre production est aussi
parce que ils sont un petit peu perdues
s'il a vu aussi c'est la vigne or tout
le monde va vers l'environnement salle
la nourriture saine parce que si on s
imagine qu est-ce que les empreintes du
manger les commerçants proposent leurs
produits tous les dimanche de 8h30 à 13h
invité à présent l'association histoire
et patrimoine de saint cyr l'école pour
un événement sur la commune laisse
entendre de l'école jean jaurès je
reçois jose le président est jean
garçons sont présents riez bienvenue en
plateau à tous les deux l samedi et
dimanche de 10h à 12h puis de 15h à 18h
présentation notamment d'une exposition
dans les locaux
on ne trouvera quoi dans cette
exposition qui me fait une petite
présentation
alors dans cette exposition vous allez
trouver la reconstitution d'une classe
d'autrefois avec le vieux mobilier savez
s'essayer ital avec les hauts cris en
porcel blanche et cetera vous retrouvez
le bureau du maître de dison de
l'instituteur et puis
il y aura un tableau noir sur lequel on
va inscrire l'année son moral si
nécessaire actuellement pour nos enfants
revient enfin on n'a jamais rien vous
allez retrouver ensuite il y a un
plusieurs panneaux d'exposition qui
retrace toute la l'histoire de l'école
jaurès tout en est on ne néglige pas
l'école précédente c'est à dire qu'il se
tenait dans l'ancienne mairie et qui a
été malheureusement détruite pendant la
guerre alors il faut dire que c'était
comme georges res qui a été construite
en 1915
on la doit au fait que l'école militaire
hébergé deux classes de garçons et il a
fallu la quitter bien sûr et par
l'apport de nouveaux militaires et son
été en guerre
il fallait donc construire cette école
les shows rêve c'est donc la plus
vieille actuellement la plus vieille
école de saint cyr est donc cette année
on fête son centième anniversaire
voyage dans le temps pour cette période
pour ce week-end il y aura même une
kermesse organisée avec des jeux d'antan
elle rate tout à fait c'est ça et quel
type de jeu alors disons que cette
partie là c'est la directrice de l'école
jean jaurès au cnam gans qui gère avec
les parents d'élèves
d'ailleurs pour cette association pour
notre association on a eu la chance
d'avoir la participation de
madame la directrice et des instituteurs
parce que j'en attends quand même dit
c'est que pendant toute la semaine on va
laisser l'accès libre aux instituteurs
et institutrices pour pouvoir travailler
avec les enfants dans cette ancienne
place donc avec l'encré violette avec
des des cahiers de l'époque on a même
édité les bons points des images où il
essayait mais comment vous allez
travailler justement pour collecter
aussi ça m'intéresse c'est plus d'un an
de travail c'est plus de long travail et
là on a la chance d'avoir une
association histoire d'école que je
tiens aussi également à remercier
qui étaient-ils en cours qui nous
prêtent entre entre guillemets on va
dire puisque bon ça quand même un
certain prix toutes ces choses là donc
c'est la municipalité d'ailleurs qui se
charge de transporter le matériel et qui
va payer cette location de matériel donc
on a cherché un peu partout et cette
association nous a donné bien sûr
énormément de matériel prêté pardonner
prêté du matériel les plus nuls les les
porte-plumes les crayons on a également
un poêle godin où on a envoyé un peu
toutes les choses qu'on avait à cette
époque là 1915 dans une école dans une
classe ce sera l'occasion pour les aînés
qui sont scolarisés actuellement de
découvrir comment ça se passait avant et
sur les générations précédentes de
l'orgue les gens rentraient aussi que
les anciens saint cyrien même ceux qui
ont fréquenté cette école
ça va leur rappeler de beaucoup de
souvenirs de cette époque c'est ouvert à
tous d'ailleurs pour cette exposition
les manifestations organisées ce week
end ce sera uniquement interne à l'école
et non au nom est ouvert à tout le
public et on prolonge sur le week-end
d'après ou ou le samedi nous allons
organiser des dictée du certificat
d'études pour les adultes le matin et
d'édicter de cm2 pour les enfants
l'après midi pour ceux qui veulent
s'inscrire et qui veulent participer
mais ce qu'on voulait surtout nous c'est
de faire participer les instituteurs et
institutrices et les enfants on a
également réalisé
toute une exposition de photos de classe
qui remonte de 1925 en gros à nos jours
où on demande aux gens s'ils ont des
souvenirs décrire les noms il manque sur
ses tableaux là s'ils se reconnaissent
sur une photo de données nous y voilà y
en a qui se sont manifestés justement à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire des
anciens élèves ces gestes de même et ses
opérations aux scolaires ça fait depuis
un bon moment qu'on s'en occupe
et voilà au forum par exemple pour
d'autres s'appuient alors j'ajouterai
simplicité c'est qu'à cette occasion
l'ancien directeur de cette école
monsieur buffet a écrit à travailler
sous les archives de l'école c'est qui a
permis de décrire ce livre vous
présenter juste devant vous je vous
l'emprunter pour le lie à la clé merci à
se salir qu'il sera mis en vente qui
sera mis en vente alors il retrace toute
l'histoire de l'écosphère de l'école
jaurès et puis dans de vieilles à une
deuxième partie qui est réalisé par jean
garçons et j'ai buffet avec qui j'avais
déjà écrit un autre livre qui était
celui de lee sur la naissance écolo la
naissance de saint cyr à travers cette
paroisse l'aja qui sont ma présentation
à rien tout ça aussi avant il est
impossible de se procurer cette 2008
dont on pourra se procurer
il y aura aussi un diaporama qui sera
projeté il y aura
un dvd réalisé par jean garçons et chenu
qui sera mis en vente alors c'est sûr
l'école jaurès principe donc il serait
intéressant c'est à mon avis c'est ce
sont des souvenirs inoubliables
pour beaucoup c'est comme je dis non
dans une ville il y a trois personnages
qui sont importants il ya le maire
évidemment il ya le curé et il ya un
instituteur et l'institutrice et même ça
va plus loin il ya les copains et les
copines moment particulièrement
important c'est certain par rapport au
ca ses ouvrages ça m'amène à parler du
travail de votre association parce que
votre association n'a pas travaillé
uniquement n'a pas été constitué pour
travailler sur le centenaire de cette
association à l'aîné à cause de la
révolution française du bicentenaire de
la révolution française qu'on a ce livre
elle donc elle est née en 1989
c'était un peu à la demande de l'état il
fallait que les communes tous les
villages sa célèbre cet anniversaire
bon allez l'association s'est créée et
puis une fois les commémorations fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait on a dissout ou
côté mais on avait tellement passionné
les gens qui on s'est dit mais il ya
beaucoup à faire sur saint cyr parce que
ça sur les gens ne connaissent pas son
passé il que ces lycéens connaissent le
lycée militaire et la fondation madame
de maintenon
si on recherche un ouvrage à l'époque
quand je suis arrivé à saint cyr page et
vous les cherchez un ouvrage sur
l'histoire de saint cyr je ne suis tombé
que c'est sur ces deux ouvrages là bon
j'ai eu des relations avec le fondateur
des musées de saint cyr le colonel
millet qui a ensuite terminé sa carrière
au débat vous cherchez partie mentale
donc voilà alors une autre mission elle
est donc été ben on va passer et petit à
petit dans une grille aujourd'hui quels
sont les différents sons d'action sur la
médiation
aujourd'hui on les dix sept adhérents
l'association mais on a beaucoup de gens
si vous voulez qu'ils sont pas forcément
adhérents mais qui répondent présent
quand on cherche des documents parce que
l'intéresse c'est effectivement de les
chercher dans les archives
mais les archives c'est très compliqué
c'est très long on y pense des journées
entières pour malheureusement pas trouvé
grand chose des fois alors que sur la
population de saint cyr on a énormément
de gens qui ont des documents ou des
anecdotes et on a plusieurs occasions de
les rencontrer et on essaye de collecter
ces documents alors on les regarde on
n'écarte pas bien sûr on laisse calme et
on les rend ce que là on travaille sur
sur cette école mais on a travaillé sur
beaucoup de d'école on a travaillé sur
les rues principales par exemple de la
ville où on a fait des sets de table
on a fait des cartes que de fin d'année
si vous voulez sur les différents de rue
il ya justement justement de la
population pour connaître l'histoire de
la commune parce que quelquefois on
expliquer un petit détachement que les
gens là aussi pas trop que ce soit les
jeunes ou les où les anciens parce que
on a on avait déjà édité deux dvd sur ce
qu'on appelait la promenade
de saint cyr l'école danse promet de la
pied dans les rues de saint cyr et on a
projeté ces deux dvd au ciné max 2 à
triolet à saint cyr gratuitement on a
fait cinq séances et on a rempli la
salle à chaque fois ils s'assoient que
des personnes anciennes ou des nouvelles
lorsque saint cyr s'agrandit énormément
à l'heure actuelle et vous avez tous les
jeunes qui viennent et qui s'installe à
saint cyr qui a envie de connaître ce
qu'il y avait à la place de leurs
immeubles où les connaissances donc on
rencontre ces gens là et on a travaillé
d'ailleurs pour des décors propriété si
vous voulez qui s'installe on a un
immeuble où la personne nous a dit moi
ça je voudrais connaître l'histoire de
mon immeuble ce qu'ils avaient avant
donc il ya eu la piscine a prévu avant
il y avait le marché oui pourquoi pas
l'école jaurès aussi et ça sera le
centième anniversaire de cet organe des
jo reste que j'ai pu avoir enfin des
témoins ou des témoignages importants ce
sont ceux de résistants bon maintenant
ils sont décédés
je souhaiterais de pierre-jean qu'avait
qui a été un grand résistant et avec
saint cyr avec d'autres bien sûr parce
que saint-cyr quand même alors ils
soient et patrimoine a eu une mission
d'abord l'appel des victimes des
anciennes victimes
on a brièvement parce qu'on va être pris
par le temps on n'a rien pour
commémorer les victimes de la guerre et
j'ai fait l'association a fait ériger
une pyramide qui se trouvent place de la
république à leur mémoire et on a pu la
financer par souscription ouvriers
ensuite il ya eu d'autres trucs mais
c'est ça la principale ou bien la
redécouverte que j'avais fait de la
croix de guerre avec palme qui avait été
décerné en 1950 caché par les
municipalités de l'époque et qui
réapparu en 1994 où là il ya une
célébration à saint cyr avec l'école
militaire
il y aura d'autres célébrations
notamment ce week end pour les santons
de sept écoles jaurès et c'est ouvert à
tout le monde pas uniquement aux
habitants de saint cyr l'école merci à
tous les deux ont poursuivi ce journal
on a pris un petit peu de retard avec
l'essentiel de la semaine et dans
l'actualité de cette semaine la
mobilisation dans le cadre du don du
sang à la veille des grandes vacances
l'établissement français du sang qui
tire la sonnette d'alarmé une nouvelle
fois elle les stocks seront
particulièrement serré sur notre secteur
c'est ce que nous a notamment expliqué
le docteur denis pagès sur ce plateau
lundi
c'est intéressant par exemple la partie
s de paris fonctionne bien
pendant les vacances d'été pour le
moment parce que les gens ont moins
d'argent pour poser placé là moi je
demande aux gens cet été et notamment
dans les deux premières semaines d'août
s'ils voient une collecte et ben
mobile ou s'ils veulent être aux frais
téléphoner un site fixe parce qu'un site
fixe au financier du don de sang total
et puis venir donner pour éviter qu'on
soit dans l'obligation une nouvelle fois
de faire des abeilles et des appels aux
dons
ce qui est désagréable et ce qui n'est
pas forcément flatteur pour
l'établissement français du sang
on vient entendre à la fin de ce
reportage seulement 3 % des franciliens
qui sont donneurs c'est très peu ça
s'explique comment est-ce que c'est
propre à notre région aussi alors c'est
propre à la structure de la région c'est
à dire qu'on a des des problèmes
identiques en californie à dessel
d'offres à hambourg cédiez gérait au
fait que dans la demie la mégalopole les
gens font énormément de transport et qu'
ils sont moins disponibles qu'en
province
ça c'est le premier point et puis on a
moins d' associations de donneurs de
sang bénévoles c'est à dire que l'on
peut quasiment en avoir autant en ile de
france que dans certains départements de
province
voilà ces gens-là nous aide beaucoup et
bat tous ceux conduits au fait que même
en dépensant beaucoup d'argent pour la
communication
en tout cas sur l'île de france on
n'arrivera pas obtenir plus de 75% des
donneurs potentiels théorique
autre sujet que nous avons développé
cette semaine la journée mondiale contre
la maltraitance des personnes âgées en
plateau mardi l'association
gérontologique des yvelines laurence
dumas psychologue coordinatrice évoqué
le silence qui règne encore aujourd'hui
sur cette question c'est un sujet
difficile les personnes ont du mal à en
parler même si elle en parle de plus en
plus et les professionnels et les
particuliers
ou encore du mal à en parler quels sont
les types de maltraitance que vous
recevez dans le département des yvelines
c'est comme au niveau national comme au
niveau national des maltraitances
physiques psychologiques financière
c'est généralement les trois
statistiquement représentait également
des maltraitances médical des ce qu'on
appelle la privation de citoyenneté ou
la violation des droits élémentaires et
puis tout ce chapitre des omissions
c'est à dire les négligences aux
personnes vulnérables
je parlais de ce service qui a été
relancé ses appels téléphoniques quel
bilan peut en faire dans les yvelines
justement le bilan alors depuis 2000
l'association a passé un contrat avec le
conseil général pour cette mission de
lutte contre la maltraitance donc de
plus en plus de dossiers de plus en plus
de personnes y compris les victimes
elles-mêmes qui appelle avec bien sûr
des proches et des professionnels
également qui signale de plus en plus
les maltraitances combien d'appels en
moyenne 250
appels annuels toutes nos éditions tous
nos reportages sont à retrouver dès à
présent sur le site internet tv fil 78
points comme pour terminer cette édition
un mot de l'invité de l'hebdo politique
de nos confrères de radio sensations
nicolas kirillovitch recevra à dimanche
à 18h constance legris députée
européenne d'ile-de-france l'est
républicain il sera notamment question
de la création par marine le pen
autre députée européenne mais de la
région nord ouest d'un groupe
parlementaire écouter cet extrait marine
le pen a réussi à créer un groupe au
parlement européen baptisé europe des
nations et des libertés
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ce groupe
est ce que c'est bon pour la démocratie
ou pas ça m'inspire beaucoup de
tristesse je dis les choses très
franchement je suis au regret de dire
que je déplore tout à fait qu'avec la
création de ce groupe puisque madame le
pen réuni les conditions au minimum 25
eurodéputés et au minimum sept
nationalités à laquelle raison de ce
groupe parlementaire ici au parlement
européen
les élus du front national a commencé
par madame le pen et son plus proche
entourage font bénéficier d'une manne
financière importante voilà dont on sait
très bien qu'elle ne va pas
intégralement être consacrée à investir
le travail législatif le travail
parlementaire le trail politique ici au
sein de l'assemblée pendant européenne
je rappelle quand même que la quasi
totalité des élus du front national dans
la dernière campagne électorale
européenne non seulement avec les
positions que l'on sait mais ça c'est la
démocratie et je ne vais pas dénié aux
gens le droit d'exprimer leurs opinions
même si quelquefois ils les expriment de
manière assez braillarde je dirais mai
dernier au parlement européen même toute
légitimité en disant que ça servait à
rien cette espèce de machin issu du
suffrage universel direct qui s'était
beaucoup mieux de revenir à un système
avec des délégations de députés
nationaux bla bla bla c'est donc il
conteste la légitimité même de
l'institution dont pourtant ils vont
prendre beaucoup d'argent l'hebdo
politique en intégralité sur radio
sensations ce week-end c'est la fin du
journal rendez-vous à lundi pour une
le semaine d'actualité locale excellent
week-end dédié bien évidemment à la
musique